في واحده من اكبر عمليه الانسحاب الروسي
التي قد تشكل نقطه تحول في حرب تقترب من
نهايه شهرها التاسع موسكو توجه قواتها
بترك الضفه اليمنى لنهر ديني برو في منطقه
خرسنا الاوكرانيه وتوجهيه ساره وزير
الدفاع الروسي امر بتنفيذ الانسحاب اقتراح
من قائد العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
الجنرال سيرجيو روفيكن الذي اقر بانه ليس
قرارا سهلا الخطوه الروسيه جاءت بعد تعرض
خارج لهجوم اوكرانيا مضاد منذ اسابيع ان
شهدت مواجهات ضاريه في الايام الاخيره
عليها الرؤوس في اوكرانيا بالكامل منذ
اطلاق العمليات العسكريه في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
وكانت الى جانب ثلاث مناطق اوكرانيه اخرى
ضمتها اليها موسكو بعد استفتاء لقي
انتقادات دوليه واسعه في وقت ابدا فيه
الكريم لان استعداده للتفاوض مع اكياف لكن
مع مراعاه الحقائق في الوقت الراهن حقائق
بدات تتغير مثل ما حدث في خرسان بلال
الوجداني العربيه